Albert Camus writes a Mythic Sisyphus
quote there's only one real serious
philosophical problem and that is
suicide
deciding whether or not life is worth
living is to answer the fundamental
question in philosophy
all other questions follow from that
so basically to be or not to be
uh do you think there's a
uh truth to that statement this question
of why live at all
um
do you think there's truth to that
statement being a really really
important question for us to answer yes
yes and what's the answer
I think the answer is yes
and I think kmu answered it yes too no I
I I love his writing and and
you know I think there was a
a streak of nihilism that I think grew
in his writing over the years and and
the thought is I think that Cameo died
by Suicide I think we're not sure of
that because it was a car accident
um but I've always read that as this
this the primary scholarly opinion and I
think it's interesting that after his
death uh a book called the first man was
published which I don't know if he had
intended to publish I don't remember the
specifics about it but it's about him as
a child right and it's interesting the
first man I mean he was the first man in
his existence right the most you know
the one that felt and experienced
everything and there's sadness and and
distress and all in that book but
there's a beauty of of life and living
and experience and and I think to
compare that beauty like that's life
even if something's difficult and scary
and sad like there's something beautiful
around the corner and he's a kind person
and a new discovery you know more what
was in him as a child and I think that
we can get jaded as we get as you and I
were just talking about a few minutes
ago we can accentuate the negative and
Foster the negative and come to a place
where we're looking for some in-depth
philosophical answer you know some thick
book you know that's going to explain
all that to us instead of the Simplicity
that we've been talking about I think
humility gratitude helps us have just
simple
positive experiences feelings of
contentment feelings of connection with
another person learning Discovery and I
think the answer to kingman's question
is yes and I think it lies in his
writing about when he was a child which
I think he saw is less important than
his later writings and the intellectual
heaviness when I think maybe he had lost
his way a little bit from the things he
understood when he was younger so
another way to talk about it and I'd
love to hear what you think is about
these broad categories
let me be started with Kierkegaard of
existentialism absurdism and nihilism
and I think Camus considered himself an
absurdist not actually an existentialist
it's kind of a middle ground where I
think existentialists
I don't want to characterize it in the
wrong way and there's a lot of different
definitions but I think existential is
ultimately
do think that there is meaning
in sort of
pursuing The Passion of life like
pursuing the mo like in living life
that's where you discover the meaning at
that individual level
of fully embracing life
and I think sort of nihilism
is uh again it's kind of like a spectrum
but now listen basically says
there's no meaning
and it doesn't matter
nothing matters
I don't even know but somehow that lands
you in a place that's totally uninspired
maybe Nautilus would disagree with that
maybe there's a way to live a creative
life in in a nihilistic mindset and I
think absurdism is somewhere in the
middle
where
pursuing meaning at all
is not a good idea
so it could kind of I think
existentially say you should be looking
for meaning and it's to be discovered in
your own actions in your own life in the
moment and uh absurdism says life is
absurd nothing makes sense don't look
for the meaning just live just be I
think that's kind of the the the later
kamu kind of
um philosophy I don't know if you can
sort of comment on these kind of nuanced
ideas here if there is no
religious guide to your life
what do you think about this kind of
search for meaning do you see that
there's some wisdom in the
existentialist perspective of
discovering it in your own life in this
passion and this kind of day-to-day
existence in the moments of your life
that bring you Joy that kind of thing
you're bringing different sort of
perspectives and trying to tease apart
like wait what are the differences in
those perspectives right and I think
what it points out is that okay we tend
to conflate things as human beings right
and to take two different things and try
and make them into one but we also I
think on the other end of the spectrum
get very overly reductionist and I think
that when we get to overly reductionist
we lose the ability to learn from
anything or to generate meaning right I
mean think about Sartre who is you know
the thought of existentialism is so
consistent with him right who on the one
hand you know wrote about you know very
clear terms like this is what it is and
this is what it isn't and here's how
you're going to make your meaning in a
very like academically pro-scribed way
but he also wrote short stories like the
wall right where there's something
totally absurd happens right as part of
the story right so I I think what ends
up happening is people either reduce
themselves or get associated with
something that is by being overly
reductionist takes us away from meaning
right the idea that look we don't know
if there is a an overarching religious
meaning or you know what we call a
religious meaning or purpose like we
don't know that right so so okay if we
take that as a given that people who say
that they know are having faith like how
Spinoza described Faith right faith is
that you don't know but you believe
anyway right it's not because you have
faith now you know something right
because I think that's a slippery slope
to the persecution of others right so so
if we say okay we don't know
then
you know we're left either deciding okay
well then to hell with everything you
know like is that movie A Strange Brew
right Bob and Doug McKenzie where like
the the breaks don't work on the car and
one of them says oh why bother steering
right so if we don't know that there's
meaning like why bother steering let's
just give up the ghost right and I don't
think that's even what the nihilist said
I mean I think bakunan said we should
get rid of everything that we've ever
created except Beethoven's Ninth
Symphony and start over from there but
so even people who are very nihilistic
or associated with that yeah a lot of
them are just not liking what we had
built right so if we accept that a lot
of what we have built as humans inside
of us and outside of us is really
counterproductive and doesn't help us
and that absurd things happen in the
world right and that often the way
social structures and systems build up
you build themselves up is absurd I
think our health care System operates in
a way that's absurd right so if we
accept that there are absurdities that
we don't know if there's truth then what
are we left with but like well let's try
and make meaning right or take it you
got set said um yoso yo Amy
circumstancia right I myself and my
circumstances right which is like look
we're we're we can't control everything
we we live in circumstances around us
but within those circumstances we can
make decisions and Define ourselves and
and I think the Brilliance of that and I
think tying it all together right in a
way that's not trying to be in a sense
it ties it all together by not trying to
answer everything concisely that yes we
can make meaning like we see that if
someone trips in front of me I could
walk around them or I could help them up
I mean no one can tell me that it
doesn't matter what I do I absolutely
reject the idea that oh I could step
over them or on them or I could help
them up and it doesn't matter oh yeah be
the try being the person on the ground
right so we create meaning but we live
in our circumstances and there are
absurdities both within us and outside
of us in our social structures and there
are a lot of things that that pretend to
have meaning that don't then there's the
shades of nihilism But ultimately
there's something going on here that's
doing the best we can in the context of
just not knowing
yeah I tend to see I don't know if it's
genetic I think I tend to think just
observing the internet the number of
memes there are uh
I think many other people are like me I
tend to see the the humor in the
absurdity
and I tend to enjoy it from that kind of
angle I see the kafka-esque nature of
society of different aspects of society
and just kind of notice the magic with a
smile
and just laugh at the circus of it all
because it is magical that the circus
all comes together it's like a little
bit out of sync and then just a guy
playing trombone but like overall it's
pretty good it's pretty good right and
we can look at that and just kind of
Marvel and go yeah right which which I
think is a relation to at least a lot of
what we in the Western World think of as
Eastern right it's like as
non-attachment right because then if
there's something absurd and it's like
not good for me you know right then I
accept that too instead of getting angry
about it and railing about it or seeing
some Cosmic meaning in it right I think
there's also a healthy non-attachment in
what you're saying too